[Applause]
thank you very much everybody
thank you very much please Major General
Matz I want to thank you and everyone at
the American battle monuments Commission
for doing just an absolutely fantastic
job exactly 100 years ago today on
November 11th 1918 World War one came to
an end thank God it was a brutal war
millions of American French and Allied
troops had fought with extraordinary
skill and valor in one of the bloodiest
conflicts in human history we are
gathered together at this hallowed
resting place to pay tribute to the
brave Americans who gave their last
breath in that mighty struggle earlier
milania and I were deeply honored to be
the guests of President McCrone and
Bridget at the Centennial commemoration
of Armistice Day it was very beautiful
and so well done to all of the French
military leaders and dignitaries in
attendance with us now thank you for
joining us as we honor the American and
French servicemembers who shed their
blood together in a horrible horrible
war but a war known as the Great War we
are also joined by many distinguished
American military leaders thank you to
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff General Joseph Dunford thank you
Jim
thank you army chief of staff general
mark Milley thank you more supreme
Allied commander Europe general Curtis
Scaparrotti general thank you that Air
Force commander Europe general Tariq
Walters thank you thank you general
thank you as well to the members of
Congress who have joined us Ralph
Abraham
Anthony Brown John Carter Paul Cook
Henry Cuellar Richard Hudson bill
Huizenga Dutch Ruppersberger John
Rutherford and Steve Stivers thank you
all very much for being with us thank
you very much I know you wanted to be
here very badly we appreciate it in the
United States Armistice Day is now
enshrined as Veterans Day we have a
number of amazing veterans with us today
including six veterans of World War two
James Blaine James where's James
James thank you thank you James Frank
debita thank you Frank
thank you very much you look so
comfortable up there under shelter as
we're getting drenched you're very smart
people Pete Despres Pete thank you very
much Gregory melech in Thank You Gregory
Stephen melnikov thank you Thank You
Stephen and Jay trimmer thank you thank
you Jay thank you you look like you're
in really good shape all of you I hope I
look like that someday
you look great America's forever in debt
and we are forever in your debt we
really appreciate you being here we're
also joined by another very special
guest a 13 year old boy from the United
States named Matthew hausky Matthew is
in the eighth grade and he worked and
saved all of his money for two years to
make this trip to France he wanted to be
here in person to honor the American
heroes of World War one Matthew thank
you you make us very proud where is
Matthew Matthew Matthew
thank you very much you're way ahead of
your time Matthew thank you
on this day in the year 1918 church
bells rang families embraced and
celebrations as you know fill the
streets like never before in towns
throughout Europe and the United States
but victory had come at a terrible cost
among the Allied forces more than 1
million French soldiers and 116 thousand
American service members had been killed
by the war's end millions more were
wounded countless would come home
bearing the lasting scars of trench
warfare and the grisly horrors of
chemical weapons during the final battle
of the war over 26,000 Americans lost
their lives and more than 95,000 were
wounded it was the single deadliest
battle in United States history
think of that 26,000 Americans lost
their lives in a battle here on the
revered grounds of sue Wren American
Cemetery
lie more than 1,500 US service members
who made the ultimate sacrifice in the
First World War
among those buried here are legendary
Marines who fought in the Battle of
belleau wood and that treacherous forest
and the surrounding fields American
marine soldiers and Allied forces fought
and they fought through hell to turn the
tide of the war and that's what they did
they turned the tide of the war it was
in that battle that our Marines earned
the nickname devil dogs arising from the
German description of their ferocious
fighting spirit John Kelly knows that
name devil dogs very well John right
earlier this year President McCrone
presented an oak sapling from bellow
wood as a gift to our nation and
during reminder of our friendship sealed
in battle we fought well together
you could not fight better than we
fought together sergeant
Eugene we're from Hazleton Pennsylvania
was one of the Marines that Bella would
Eugene raced straight into a barrage of
enemy fire like no one has ever seen
before to bandage his friends wounds and
carry him back to safety
months later Eugene was mortally wounded
he passed away one day after Christmas
his mother would come right here to
mourn by the grave of her precious son
she loved him so much she was one of the
thousands of American moms and dads
whose beloved children found their final
resting place on the hillside of su Ren
H of these marble crosses and Stars of
David marks the life of an American
warrior great great warriors they are
who gave everything for a family country
God and freedom through rain hail snow
mud poisonous gas bullets and mortar
they held the line and pushed onward to
victory was a great great victory costly
victory but a great victory never
knowing if they would ever again see
their families or ever again hold their
loved ones here are the words of a young
soldier named sergeant Paul Maynard from
a letter he wrote only a few days before
the end of the war dear mother I think
of you all at home and I know if I am
spared to get back that I shall
appreciate home more than ever ever
before it will seem like heaven to me to
be once more where there is peace and
only peace on November 11th 1918 Paul
died in the final hours of
just before the end no sadly he did not
make it he was among the countless young
men who never returned home but through
their sacrifice they ascended to peace
in heaven rest in peace Paul the
American and French Patriots of World
War one embody the timeless virtues of
our two republics honor and courage
strength and valor love and loyalty
grace and glory it is our duty to
preserve the civilization they defend it
and to protect the peace they so nobly
gave their lives to secure one century
ago it is now my great honor to present
Major General William Matz with an
American flag as a symbol of our
nation's gratitude to the American
battle monuments the Commission has done
such an incredible job in general we
very much appreciate it today we renew
our sacred obligation to memorialize our
fallen heroes on the soil where they
rest for all of eternity
thank you very much in general this is a
great honor thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you all god bless you this has
been a wonderful two days we spent in
France and this is certainly the
highlight of the trip thank you very
much appreciate it